eux c'est avec cette seule certitude que
je suis parti le 8 décembre 2012
en jordanie avec mes chaussettes et avec
mes aiguilles les chaussettes
c'est très important parce qu'il fait
froid en hiver les aiguilles parce que
je suis acupunctrice de métier je suis
parti je suis arrivé en jordanie dans
l'un des deux plus grandes quant au
monde
le camp de saad hariri qui a un quand
syrien et je me suis intégré est associé
à des équipes militaires qui étaient des
médecins de guerre des équipes
militaires marocaines ces médecins
faisaient un travail merveilleux puisque
il ressuscitait des blessés de guerre
qui arrivait avec des jambes en lambeaux
des blessés amputés qui traversaient la
frontière syrienne à pied ont des
brouettes ont portés par leurs proches
et moi j'étais là avec mes aiguilles
parce qu'il faut savoir que dans ces
camps l'a souvent la morphine manque
cruellement alors j'étais là pour
soulager la douleur de ses blessés la
douleur des membres fantômes la douleur
des brûlés et la douleur des amputés
c'est toujours la première fois que
c'est le plus difficile mais j'ai
continué avec la petite association que
j'ai créée je suis parti tout au long de
cette frontière syrienne
plusieurs fois pour aller continuer de
soulager la douleur de ces personnes là
si bien que au printemps 2014
je suis sur place dans le nord de l'irak
au moment de la plus grande offensive
conduite par un dash de mes yeux je n'ai
jamais vu autant de gens arriver et
affluer en si peu de temps
imaginez-vous deux millions et demi de
personnes qui fuient qui abandonnent
leurs foyers juste pour sauver leur peau
à cette époque là j'étais associé avec
un médecin
un médecin local et toujours avec mes
petites aiguilles on décide d'aller dans
sa voiture et avec quelques cartons
d'aiguilhe et de médicaments à la
rencontre de ces réfugiés au départ
c'était vraiment très artisanal
puisqu'on était avec notre voiture on
s'adapter aux conditions de météo
il faut savoir que dans ces régions-là
fait très chaud il ya beaucoup de vent
beaucoup de sable et la nuit tombe trop
nous travailler avec nos lampes
frontales et on essaie de travailler
pour soulager un maximum de douleur et
de blessés de guerre au fur et à mesure
je voyais l'étendue des dégâts et
surtout les besoins alors on a décidé et
on a imaginé un concept un concept
finalement pratique et adapté à cette
situation là je suis rentré à paris on a
acheté un camion
on a décidé de médicaliser on l'a envoyé
par bateau depuis marseille jusqu'en
irak
on a inauguré ainsi notre première
clinique mobile en janvier 2015
c'était merveilleux on allait au chevet
de ces gens là et grâce à ce véhicule on
pouvait aller un peu plus loin à chaque
fois sortir de la ville
allez dans les campagnes jusqu'aux
montagnes ce qui était merveilleux aussi
c'est que j'ai pu commencer à quitter
mes aiguilles pour répondre à des
besoins de plus en plus important dans
les rues il y a tellement d'enfants et
de femmes il faut savoir que seulement 9
% de ces réfugiés a accès à des camps
tout le reste
occupent les espaces publics alors on a
commencé à recruter un puis deux puis
trois médecins
tout ce qu'on a recrutés parmi les
réfugiés
ainsi on a pu leur donner du travail et
les aider à retrouver une dignité dans
les semaines et dans les mois qui ont
suivi
nous sommes passés de 1 à plusieurs
dispensaires mobiles
c'est bien qu'en 2015 on a pu donner
40000 soins sur 30 sites identifiés par
nos équipes
avec quatorze médecins qu on a embauché
pourquoi je fais ça on me pose souvent
la question
moi aussi je me la pose souvent
est-ce que c'est mes origines je suis
une petite fille de déportés arméniens
j'ai eu cette chance de naître en france
dans un pays en paix et je me suis
toujours dit que le jour où je pourrais
moi aussi tendre la main aux autres
comme on l'a fait pour ma famille je le
ferai alors je suis toujours
acupunctrice de métier je suis marié
j'ai trois enfants juillet à paris mais
je continue et j'ai décidé de continuer
au départ je pensais que c'est mission
durerait six mois le temps pour ces
exilés de rentrer chez eux que la guerre
s'arrête
deux ans plus tard nous sommes toujours
là et on continue pourquoi parce que eux
c'est nous parce que eux ils ont mis
leur vie en danger et ils viennent
jusqu'à chez nous si bien qu'on les voit
partout autour de notre pays sur toutes
nos frontières nous avons décidé
également de mettre en place un bus à
calais je vous disais je pensais que
cette mission durerait six mois deux ans
plus tard nous sommes toujours là nous
avons mis en place un bus à calais mais
c'est très difficile
ça reste très difficile et pour
plusieurs raisons
en irak on travaille dans une zone où on
subit beaucoup de menaces n'est pas loin
des lignes de front c'est aussi
difficile parce que on est souvent
l'objet d' instrumentalisation on
dépense beaucoup d'argent chaque mois
pour pouvoir financer tous ces salaires
financer ces ses soins pour donner à
chaque fois six mille soin par mois il
c'est difficile aussi pour une femme de
venir s'imposer comme ça dans cette
région de lorient où c'est la loi de
l'homme finalement qui prévaut et puis
c'est aussi très difficile pour une
troisième raison c'est toujours très
décourageant de voir cette misère qui ne
s'arrête jamais de voir l'étendue de ce
drame humain on ne voit jamais le bout
c'est très décourageant
c'est écrasant
j'ai pas le courage d'arrêter parce que
eux c'est nous merci
[Applaudissements]